so Sal a lot of people were angry with
your father for the amount of extended
family he's now created hmm
he you know and as you described your
sister went on check DNA and found two
new siblings two young ladies yes who
are your sisters right half sisters and
it was a shock to the family and for
some bizarre reason your sister decided
to invite them for Father's Day with
your mom they're crazy so we found out
just coincidentally that his two
daughters have the same exact birthdays
as my two sisters oh my god you mean the
day your sisters were born yes absurd a
in the months but not the year right but
coincidentally though oh my god I know
you can wear to God so I say to my dad
dad these two girls have the same exact
birthdays as my two sisters your two
daughters as well you have four
daughters with two birthdays that are
identical I go how what do you make of
this and he goes that's um that's a
miracle we're gonna hit the lotto but he
goes don't you see it we take those two
the first number and the second number
we play the pick four that's the pick
four we have to play it all week because
we to make millions
oh my go so this is the light at the end
of the tunnel you meet your daughter and
the sign is it's your gonna win the lies
I think that just because they have the
same birthday he's gonna hit the lotto
he thinks it's a sign everything is fine
everything's a sign like if he has two
daughters with the same number let's say
he has Pat he's a passionate man
passionate about cheating and lottery
yes I mean the guy's really into it